"THAT'S UP TO THE DEMOCRATS."
BRET?
>> Bret: JOHN, THANKS.
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS JUST STARTED
UP RIGHT NOW, THE HEAD OF THE
SENATE A PRORATION COMMITTEE
SAYS THERE IS A 50/50 CHANCE
OF A BUDGET DEAL BEFORE THE
CLOCK RUNS OUT FRIDAY NIGHT.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
IS ON CAPITOL HILL WITH THE
LATEST.
>> THE TOP OPERATORS IN CONGRESS
TRYING TO GET BORDER SECURITY
TALKS BACK ON TRACK AT A TRUE
CRUCIAL STAGE.
THEY APPEAR TO BE HEADING TO A
BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE WITH
$2 BILLION IN PORT SECURITY
FUNDING WHEN MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL SAYS SOME
DEMOCRATS PULLED A STUNT.
>> SOME HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
RISKING A SECOND PARTIAL
DEMOCRAT SHUTDOWN BY CALLING FOR
THIS ABSURD LAST-MINUTE POISON
PILL.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE DEMANDING A CAP
ON IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT DETENTION BEDS.
>> THEY ARE TARGETING -- WE DO
NOT WANT A CAP ON THAT.
>> ALLIES OF THE WHITE HOUSE SAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD TAKE THE
MONEY BUT NOT WITH THAT KIND OF
RESTRICTION IN TIME IS RUNNING
OUT.
THERE IS A 72 HOUR RULE DESIGNED
TO GIVE MEMBERS TIME TO READ THE
BILL BEFORE VOTING ON IT, SO A
DEAL TO AND THAT LESS THAN
24 HOURS TO MEET FRIDAY'S
DEADLINE.
A DEMOCRAT INVOLVED IN THE TALKS
ISN'T READY TO HIT THE PANIC
BUTTON JUST YET.
>> EVERY NEGOTIATION HITSB
>> EVERY NEGOTIATION HITSM
>> EVERY NEGOTIATION HITSS
>> EVERY NEGOTIATION HITSH
>> EVERY NEGOTIATION HITSE
ROAD.
AS LONG AS WE STAY FOCUSED IN A
BICAMERAL WAY TO GET THIS DONE,
I HOPEFUL WE GET IT DONE.
>> MOST LAWMAKERS ON BOTH SIDES
SAY THAT SHOULD BE AVOIDED AT
ALL COSTS.
>> I DO NOT KNOW OUTSIDE OF 1-2
KNUCKLEHEADS OUT HERE THAT ENJOY
THAT PARTICULAR SHUTDOWN
ATMOSPHERE.
DON'T DO IT.
COME TO A COMPROMISE BUT LET'S
GET ON WITH DOING THE THINGS
REALLY IMPORTANT HERE.
>> IF ALL ELSE FAILS, THERE ARE
THOUGHTS THAT THEY COULD PASS
THE NONIMMIGRATION FUNDING BILLS